qu'est-ce que vous auriez préféré en
fait 25 millions d'albums avec un
morceau ou un million d'albums avec 25
morceaux
et nous accueillons notre terrien du
samedi 20h ce soir Patrick Hernandez
bonsoir ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà alors Patrick Hernandez bonsoir
bonsoir cette chanson vous en avez vendu
25 millions d'exemplaires vous nous
raconterez pourquoi au départ personne
n'en voulait puis son succès planétaire
et ce qu'elle vous rapporte encore tous
les jours bref à 20h vous nous
raconterez votre histoire vous direz
tout
[Musique]
Patrick Hernandez rebonsoir
ah vous êtes né le 6 avril
1949 au Blanc-Mesnil en
Seine-Saint-Denis votre père était
pharmacien et votre mère comptable alors
faites des études sans problème au lycée
de Gonesse en fait vous voulez devenir
prof d'anglais au départ à la base oui
c'est ce que je voulais à la base et
c'est pour ça que vos parents vous
envoient en Angleterre
erreur grosse erreur et là évidemment
vous découvrez les Beatles et la bride
pop et vous vous dites c'est ça que je
veux faire oui quand je vois les Beatles
à la télévision la première fois en noir
et blanc chantant chill of you je dis je
veux faire Beatles dans la vie je veux
faire ça et donc j'ai tout abandonné à
ce moment là et là vous commencez à
jouer de la guitare finis les études et
ensuite vous perfectionnez d'ailleurs à
la guitare dans les orchestres de Bâle
dans la région de Périgueux que tu as
fait quelques années plus tard vous
montez à Paris pour une audition chez
les disques flèche qui était la société
de Claude François et là avant même de
voir Claude François une Claudette vous
dit vous devriez rencontrer un groupe
qui s'appelle Paris Palace Hôtel il
cherche un guitariste chanteur et en
fait je tombe amoureux purement et
simplement de la musique que ces gens
faisaient voilà et j'oublie complètement
mon contrat
en fait jamais et je pars avec eux en
galère voilà alors le groupe Paris
Palace Hôtel PPA va sortir 3,45 tours
faut le dire sans beaucoup de succès
Patrick sans aucun succès
et en 1974 vous préparez un album sous
la houlette du producteur belge Jean van
loup
et c'est à cette époque que vous écrivez
donc Born to Be Alive en fait au départ
vous chantez born to be wild parce que
c'est la chanson de steppenhool tout à
fait et donc l'idée de Live me vient
alors par la suite je me suis aperçu
finalement que c'était un pléonasme en
anglais pour être en vie voilà et en
même temps c'est très fort et cependant
les Américains et les Anglais et les
Anglo-Saxons en général ne m'en ont
jamais tenu rigueur parce
qu'effectivement on n'est pas on est né
forcément vivant mais on vit souvent une
vie étriquée voilà c'est ce que veut
dire la chanson
alors ce qu'il faut dire d'abord c'est
que cette chanson au départ c'est un
rock
un roc pur oui donc vous chantez Born to
Be Alive en rock pendant trois ans avec
péph en 1978 le groupe split nous séparé
et là vous partez vivre dans une cabane
dans les bois dans le Périgord tu vois
c'est des pots de Baba quoi oui c'est
une époque Baba puis j'ai une rupture un
peu douloureuse donc je pars
effectivement en introspection dans les
bois une cabane qui m'est prêtée par les
potes alors vous êtes en plein tripes
bucolique quand le producteur Jean vend
le loup vous appelle il vous demande de
le rejoindre en Belgique au studio Cathy
appartenant à Marc Arian tu te souviens
de marque à rien à la marque alliance
c'est celui qui chantait elle avait un
corps très fin un joli corps un corps de
mannequin le jour où l'esprit fut
distribué le bon Dieu avait du l'oublier
elle était bête à manger du foin et
c'est dommage car je l'aimais bien c'est
sympa faut sortir la nouvelle version
faut sortir
donc vous partez là-bas pour enregistrer
une chanson intitulée mais qui Love et
là un jour pendant une pause dans le
studio ou fredonnez Born to Be Alive les
gens dans le look avec lequel j'avais
donc déjà travaillé l'écoute d'une
manière différente il l'écoute comme ça
d'une manière très dépouillée je suis
avec une guitare une voix et à la fin de
l'écoute il me dit écoute on continue de
travailler sur ton on est en train de
faire mais je vais réfléchir à un projet
autour de ça parce qu'en fait lui il
vous dit pourquoi t'en fais pas un
morceau disco vous vous détestez le
disco à l'époque vous êtes dans le
rock'n roll forcément vous trouvez que
le disco ça craint mais oui c'est de la
musique au kilomètre je déteste ça pour
moi mais lui il croit vraiment vous
comprenez pas bien ça fixette mais comme
il en démord pas mais vous le faites et
quand il écoute la maquette que l'on
avait fait il nous dit vous avez fait
une bombe atomique et nous on comprend
pas très bien parce qu'en fait cette
chanson moi je la traîne depuis 74
et il prend donc le disque terminé
évidemment il le présente aux maisons de
disques il se fait remarrer de partout
il y a personne trouve ça bien tout
confondu vraiment tout confondu on s'est
fait jeter pendant 6 mois partout
partout partout partout partout alors
c'est pas grave il dit je vais faire le
disque moi-même je vais le produire je
vais le presser moi-même ça marche
toujours pas il l'a le fils de ce genre
en loup à l'idée de presser un maxi
single pour les DJ dans les dans les
boîtes quoi et en fait même les 10
jockey trouve ça trop rapide parce que
ça ressemble un peu la chanson de
Sylvester you mec me feel qui est un peu
accéléré donc les gens disent
attendaient les gens peuvent pas danser
là-dessus dès qu'on la met sa vie de la
piste donc c'est pas une bombe atomique
là c'est une catastrophe atomique c'est
une catastrophe atomique et on va on va
voir un copain en Italie qui qui tient
un petit label à Milan
et il trouve ça génial donc il dit moi
je sors ça tout de suite immédiatement
et là mon espace d'une semaine 10 jours
ça explose purement et ça c'est
incroyable ça devient numéro 1 en Italie
vous vous étiez à deux doigts
d'abandonner enfin je veux dire bon plus
personne
n'y croyait ensuite après l'Italie il y
aura l'Allemagne la Belgique la Suisse
l'Angleterre vous êtes dans le top 10
anglais ce qui est rarissime pour une
chanson française les USA et bien sûr la
France et vous allez en vendre 25
millions d'exemplaires mesdamnés
incroyable incroyable histoire de cette
chanson que personne ne voulait et là
vous entamez une tournée de promo
mondial vous allez au Japon dans un
Australie vous allez au Chili en fait
vous avez chanté Born to Be Alive mille
fois dans des télévisions à cette époque
là
et puis en tant qu'auteur compositeur
vous gagnez évidemment beaucoup d'argent
mais dans les années qui vont suivre
vous allez récupérer les droits de
production et les droits d'édition
aujourd'hui vous êtes propriétaire à
100% de la chanson ce qui est
effectivement fait de moi un homme très
heureux parce que c'est une chanson qui
a une verdeur incroyable que l'on entend
autant aujourd'hui qu'on l'entendait en
1979 dans tous les pays du monde et dans
toutes les discothèques du monde et dans
tous les balles populaires du monde
entier et donc je suis un homme heureux
effectivement et cette chanson on peut
dire vous rapporte entre 1000 et 1500
euros par jour c'est tout à fait ça mais
c'est tout cumulé et bien évidemment
c'est pas mal la banque les impôts ne
passent bien faire un petit coucou en
Belgique bravo non non je suis resté ici
là pendant la tournée de de promo
mondial vous composez vous enregistrez
un album ça a coûté une fortune ce
coup-là c'est à dire vous allez en
studio à Londres Atlanta un Nashville
voulu un château enfin je mais voilà
dans cet album il n'y a pas de titre
phare et votre erreur c'est en fait de
pas avoir accepté que quelqu'un vous le
compose par exemple quand on prend Kim
Carnes
l'album c'est son album mais la chanson
phare de l'album c'est pas elle qui l'a
écrit tout à fait et c'est ce qui me
manque j'aurais dû avoir la lucidité en
fait d'appeler à l'aide surtout qu'à
l'époque quand on est numéro un dans le
monde entier l'aide vient tout seul il
lui reste tout le monde aurait été
on ne sait jamais alors aujourd'hui
Patrick tout va bien vous menez une vie
paisible chez vous à l'Isle-sur-Sorgue
dans le dans le Vaucluse vous avez un
home studio mais vous ne faites de la
musique que pour vos potes quoi c'est un
peu sage fait de la musique pour moi
d'abord parce que c'est un besoin sur un
peu comme un peintre qui a besoin de
pain le matin de temps en temps quand il
se réveille il m'arrive de temps en
temps de faire des duos avec des gens
pour le plaisir de les faire aussi donc
j'ai fait un duo avec George et ben par
exemple au Brésil et donc voilà je fais
de la musique pour le pour le plaisir de
faire de la musique alors qu'est-ce que
vous auriez préféré en fait 25 millions
d'albums avec un morceau ou un million
d'albums avec 25 morceaux j'aurais
préféré faire une carrière normale c'est
à dire en vente trois du premier en
vendre 100 du second etc et monter et
finir effectivement par un tube mondial
le fait d'avoir fait un succès
planétaire des et vraiment d'abord c'est
une bénédiction aujourd'hui et je suis
conscient que c'est une vraie
bénédiction pour le compos je suis c'est
un peu une galère quand même parce que
j'aurais adoré
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu